Hun's kuba here disguised as a Flula
Borg at the roasting of Bruce Willis aka
John McClane not certain when he changed
his name I'm going to speak with
visitors of this roasting and find out
whether all my detonators give me some
tips of how I can defeat him finally I
think you can only defeat him with words
words so write a haiku you know don't go
after his waterfalls it's all about the
eye contact and the list you know this
throws action here is off everybody
knows that that's a confusion so I
should say confusing
but stronger kung fu film film yes
exactly
luckily he's getting very old age ain't
nothing but a no age is actually
important you know he's often barefoot
so I'd put a lot of obstacles on the
ground tell that he lives in air ducts
so I would just pump a lot of gases
through those ducts and you know take
his wife are you guys friends now have
you been able to wrap things up I sent
him to MySpace page requests just
nothing
how can the same witch happen to the
same guy twice I think it's actually
five times now you know that's what life
is it's just like the same it over and
over so I hope I never like have to do
this again you know we're out the
detonators
where am i definite us who they're
hidden in the gimps outfit I'm
pretending to know what you're talking
about because I literally have never
seen any of his films here
is that what you wanted me to do and
that's the detonator oh here it is
that's not what is this what is this
Trapper Keeper my detonators are up
bearish that's with a
you